adele and rich paul just had a sexy
courtside date night i feel very lucky
the two stepped out on tuesday to watch
the los angeles lakers take on the
golden state warriors at the staples
center in la the 33 year old singer
looked glam in brown leather pants and a
matching top which she paired with a
coordinating louis vuitton coat
meanwhile the 39 year old sports agent
sported gray pants a black turtleneck
and a jacket to the game which saw the
lakers lose by seven points while celebs
like justin bieber usher kevin hart jack
nicholson sawedy and floyd mayweather
watched on and an eyewitness tells et
that adele and rich were quote chatting
the whole night and seemed very close
adding that both were very engaged in
the game but this isn't the first game
that the pair has attended together well
we could be here a while in fact they
first sparked romance rumors back in
july when they attended an nba finals
game together in phoenix arizona after
the game an eyewitness told et that the
pair seemed quote very happy together
quote they had their eyes on each other
almost as much as they did on the game
they were laughing and cheering and
having a great time and i felt blessed
in september the pair went insta
official when adele shared this pic of
them at a wedding together and the next
month adele confirmed to their
relationship for the first time during
an interview with vogue quote we're very
happy i just love being around him i
just love it i'm incredibly humbled by
it the songbird added that rich handles
her fame well unlike other men she dated
following her divorce from simon kaneki
whom she shares a nine-year-old son
angelo with quote he's not frazzled by
it at all it feels like it's consistent
and considerate enough that i don't care
who knows he's great he's so
funny he's so smart you know and if all
that wasn't sweet enough adele said this
quote rich just incredibly arrived i
don't feel anxious or nervous or
frazzled it's quite the opposite it's
wild
[Music]